if it wasn't the will of God for a woman
to preach or teach then why does it say
that Aquilla and his wife Priscilla were
over a church that was inside their
house basically she was a co-pastor Oh
no in John
20:7 Jesus told Mary to go tell the
other disciples that he ascended to the
father it was a woman but I thought
women couldn't preach though matter of
fact we can't forget Phoebe right most
don't even know who she is yet the Bible
says that she was a servant in the
church that word servant originally
means that she was a teacher or a pastor
and that word that doesn't line up with
what I'm trying to say I'm just going to
change what that word means okay why is
it that Christians for about 18800 years
accepting the last 100 200 years they
all thought that women are not supposed
to be priests why is it what did they
all get wrong that this guy got right